for 60 years Barn Buddy's rescue has
been helping abandoned animals here in
the valley from horses to tortoises
everything in between
but this is the season of rabbits
especially after the Easter holiday many
are left following the celebration our
Lorna Grady joins us live from the farm
in Centennial hills with more on their
mission how you can help and you've got
Archie there in your arms do you have a
new buddy there Lauren
I do Heather good morning yeah we got
Archie in our arms I am covered in
rabbit hair we are on peacock alert
after am incident uh with our cameraman
Stacy but for now here I am joined by
Sharon Linson Bert like you said BART to
talk more about you know it is rabbit
season
um unfortunately even Monday you guys
had about three abandoned here and and
kind of dumped on you guys yes we've got
to do something to get the community to
stop dumping and abandoning rabbits if
anyone has a problem with their rabbit
and they can't they just possibly can't
continue to keep them animal foundation
animal shelter animal control and then
possibly give me a call afterwards and
see if we can find a decent home a
loving home a permanent home for your
bunny if you can't keep it but dumping
it somewhere is just unacceptable
unacceptable so we've got to do
something to get the community to stop
that rabbits out in the in the community
just just doesn't work not only for the
rabbit but for all those people that
care and then all of a sudden they've
got one in their yard Garden their dogs
after it's just not a good situation
right of course and you know on that
topic you know we uh we've got a we love
a hop and good time with some word play
and right here is the brand new rabbit
hat that opened up here Hazel's house of
hairs and so uh climate controlled area
bringing this the rabbits in summer
months coming around God we've got to
get our bunnies in out of the weather in
the summertime we've now uh getting our
cages built this week they should be in
uh by the by the time the summer weather
hits and that way we'll be able to care
for all of these bunnies a little bit
more uh interior which is a good thing
for them we really need the community
support we need sponsors for these
rabbits we need people we need people to
come and be a part of these rabbits
lives and come out here and help us
volunteer to take care of them it takes
an awful lot it takes a community it
takes a community to come out here and
help us care for all of these animals
all of the animals here have been
abandoned or dumped and that's a sad
thing
he said volunteer come out here animal
uh visitation it's weekends 9 A.M to 4
P.M coming out to the animals you can
get married during that time you can
have fun events during this time uh
definitely a great resource you guys
back at the station already know that
though yeah it's a really great spot
just such a nice nice place to do so
many different things here in the valley
love it send a little extra love there
to RT thank you Lauren